it took security forces 30 hours to end
the siege of the hayat hotel in
mogadishu a special police task force
deployed to the somali capital killed
the attackers and freed the hostages
the security operation that took place
in the hyatt hotel ended at midnight
during the operation security forces
focused on measures to ensure the safety
of citizens who were stuck in the hotel
more than 100 people including women and
children were rescued
the attack began on friday night when a
shabbat gunman detonated two car bombs
at the entrance of the hotel before
storming it
dozens of people were trapped in the
building
just minutes before the blast two of my
friends told me they would be leaving
but seconds later they were both killed
people fled in confusion they were all
running towards places they thought
would be safe the hotel began to fill
with smoke and flames i saw one of the
hotel guards bleeding and another man
wounded
the hayat is popular among businessmen
government personnel and politicians
this is the first attack al-shabab has
carried out in mogadishu since hassan
sheikh muhammad was elected president
for a second time in may
despite a year's long offensive by the
government and african union forces the
siege is a reminder that the armed group
still poses a threat to somali security
is following the story for us from
nairobi neighboring kenya and joins me
now so haru really the governments say
they've recaptured the hotel the abshib
fighters are dead but it still leaves
many more questions unanswered for the
moment
well people who haven't heard from their
loved ones are waiting near the hotel
for any kind of news we've been told
that parts of the hotel collapsed so
there's a fear that some people could
still be trapped in there and that's why
some people are saying the death toll
could rise
security officials are still combing the
area looking through security footage
looking for evidence this is a big hotel
popular with politicians and lawmakers
but it seems with this attack many
civilians were targeted when the new
president came into power in may he
promised to tackle insecurity so
questions are being asked like how did
al-shabab manage to get into the hotel
why did it take security forces so long
to bring things under control 30 hours
and how is the government going to
prevent more attacks from happening in
recent weeks there have been smaller
attacks by al-shabab near the border
with ethiopia and in those times europe
has managed to push al-shabab back so
concerns are now being raised of course
is
what is being done about the security
situation in somalia it's a fairly new
government they're still trying to get
their things in order and the concern
people are having now is
is this new president going to be able
to reign in al-shabab and stop future
attacks in mogadishu he said he's
willing to speak to al-shabab leaders
but he said the time is not yet right
for that now hala mutasa for us in
nairobi thank you
alai wassami is a lecturer at the
university of east africa and a former
education minister in puntland he says
al-shabab's hotel attack was a
sophisticated operation and probably
involved significant planning
magazine was recently
in a very calm situation there was no
major incident
since
zobe in 2017
everyone was surprised and i think one
of the main contributors of this
operation was that the government is in
transit
uh in transition and there is still
no clear command
for many many forces the coordination
was very difficult and i think
uh the situation
was not expected as fast as it had
happened
are very formidable air force still
mogadishu
areas they have many many eyes and
they have access of many many facilities
i think it's not a surprise that the
operation started within but the scale
the casualties and longevity has took
was all extraordinary the government was
avoiding to uh politicize the security
sector there was a very very criticism
for the last government
for using the uh
you know security forces uh in a
political context i think one of the key
issues that
made the government into both bone the
change in command except for the nissa
which is the national security and
intelligence force was to offer that
kind of backlash but i think uh
the situation now you know rebounded
back that there should be a change in
the goal in the school sector there
should be more coordination and the
government has to prioritize security
from everything else